some would argue that a Grand Theft Auto
feature is an no-brainer everything the
franchise has to offer could arguably be
turned into a thrilling action-packed
crime drama there was even a moment when
a controversial grammy-winning artist
was pitched as the star of a grand theft
Automotion picture according to Kurt euu
a seasoned player in the gaming industry
shortly after Grand Theft Auto 3 came
out he spoke with GTA co-creator Sam
Hower about a possible film adaptation
and then an alluring offer came into
play youing said on the BBC podcast
Bugsy Malone's grandest game and
remember taking a call at about 4:00
a.m. from one of the producers in LA
with an offer to make a film and he said
Kirk we've got Eminem to Star and it's a
Tony Scott film 5 million on the nose
are you interested but when he told
Hower about it he was shocked when the
GTA head honcho said he was not
interested after that the idea of the
game making the jump to the big screen
disappeared